[Music]
car chases have long been a staple of
action movies they seem to have reached
their peak lately in the fate of the
Furious the latest chapter in the Fast
and the Furious franchise car chases
have evolved a lot over the years here
are the ones that innovated and set new
standards for how to make an amazing
chase sequence Buster Keaton was best
known for his madcap chases like in 1924
Sherlock jr. which involved cars trains
and a motorcycle with no driver it was
very innovative first time for instance
a shot in which kian almost gets hit by
an oncoming train has actually shot
backwards Keaton meanwhile did all his
own stunts in 1968 bullet Steve McQueen
raced through the hilly streets of San
Francisco the cars often reach speeds of
110 miles per hour filming took three
weeks and in the end produce a chase
that is just under ten minutes long the
chief sends right outside the city and
takes full advantage of the Bay Area's
crazy geography three years later the
French Connection took it to the next
level during the film's most famous
scene Gene Hackman playing Popeye Doyle
goes after an elevated train in Brooklyn
many of those crashes you see are
completely real the film would go on to
win the Oscar for Best Picture not every
chase has to be terrifying the mall
chase in 1980s the blues brothers showed
that in the same vein as Buster Keaton
some of the best chases are the funniest
producers rented out an old shopping
mall in suburban Illinois and left it in
complete room as these movies and the
fast the furious franchise show all the
best car chases are filmed not in front
of a green screen but rather out in the
real world Hollywood has faltered a bit
when trying to completely CGI car
stunned the car crash in 2001 the long
team of spider was probably meant to be
terrifying but in reality it's
unintentionally hilarious rather than
relying entirely on CGI the best action
film vday use it to sweeten and enhance
practical stunts and effects one of the
best chases ever is in 2006's children
of men the whole chase consists of a
single shot lasting around four minutes
they built an innovative rig to capture
all the action in a small space without
resorting to a green screen it was
nearly impossible to film you'd never
know from watching that CGI was used to
ensure continuity most of the best
chases in recent memory come from Mad
Max fury road director George Miller
shot the breathtaking apocalyptic car
chases in the deserts of Africa most of
those cars were really there many of
those explosions actually happened
post-production was used as a chance to
touch up the edges a bit this brings us
back to the Fast and the Furious series
as the movies have grown in popularity
their budgets have grown and so is their
ability to pull off some insane stunts
watch how this tank emerges from a truck
in Fast and Furious 6
the state of the furious they had the
freedom to throw pile of cars off a
six-story parking garage they also got
to race in the streets of Havana
becoming the first major American film
the shooting Cuba the climactic action
seen the new films most ambitious was
actually filmed in Iceland those
explosions you see are real they really
did sink a Lamborghini but they also use
their imaginations a bit because how
else did you expect for them to get a
giant submarine in there from the 1920s
up to today the best chasey and continue
to innovate they combine a filmmakers
magic touch with whatever vehicles they
can crash if only Buster Keenan Vin
Diesel could have faced off in a street
race what's your favorite chase scene
let us know in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe